the last type of Justice which Aristotle
discusses as he's distinguishing the
different types or sorts or forms of
justice apart from each other in nikhil
mccain ethics book v which is focused
entirely on the question of what is
justice is what gets often translated as
equity or the equitable and that's not a
bad translation but it can be a little
bit misleading because we don't want to
associate it with one of the other
senses of equity that that often gets
used in our society which is where
you're building equity in some sort of
property or in some sort of concern or
in some sort of project it doesn't mean
equity in the absence
it means equity in the sense that which
is appropriate so when we say something
is equitable like a decision is
equitable or a division of labor or a
division of assets is equitable what
we're really saying is that it fits the
case it's appropriate to the parties
that are involved it actually extends to
their particular circumstances which
might you know require exceptions to be
made and Aristotle has this great
metaphor where he talks about the ruler
used by the craftsmen of Lesbos which is
made of lead which allows you to
actually mold it around things so that
you know for example it's easy to
measure something along this way all
right you just get a measuring tape or a
yardstick but if you want to measure
around you need a different type of
measuring device they didn't they you
know they knew how to use rope for that
but he has in mind something that's a
little bit more fixed so he talks about
this Lenin ruler that you can you could
mold around things and he says that
equity he actually has some few puzzles
about it at the beginning
in talking about this he says well is it
is it something different than justice
because if it is that would be kind of
strange because it does seem to be
something just but at the same time it
seems to be different than the other
forms of justice it doesn't seem to fall
under them so which is is it is it the
same as or is it different from justice
and Aristotle's account which
distinguishes a number of different
senses of justice it's possible to say
well it's one of the basic notions of
justice it's not the entirety of it but
it's one of the basic notions and this
is what allows him to actually say it's
better than one particular kind of
justice one which we've looked at in
another court concept video justice is
legality or legal justice or law
law-abiding us why is it better than
that well he says that it's actually a
sort of correction of legal justice why
would legal justice need to be corrected
well even when the laws are well made
Aristotle thinks there are going to be
some things that just don't fit the laws
that well so if you were to apply the
law by its letter rigorously the same
across all cases you would end up doing
some things that in the sense that
you're actually following procedure
you're actually following the rules
you're treating every single case the
same or at least you know similar cases
similarly you are doing the right thing
you are being just in that sense but
there's a there's another sense of
justice that's being trampled on or left
out or or ignored or diminished and this
is what he's calling equity that's this
correction so this is a very common
experience that we have we you know we
have all sorts of situations
institutions settings in
we have rules governing them we could
think of the laws that govern say
traffic for example what would happen if
they strictly enforced speed limits all
across the board everywhere the traffic
would actually get pretty screwed up
because since there's actually a little
bit of play built into the system you
know as a matter of fact a lot of the
people that I know and I would include
myself among these have the view that
the speed limit is what you should you
know more or less stick to especially if
it's raining or foggy or snowy and you
might even go under it but it's okay to
go a little bit above it provided that
you know what you're doing and now if
you go ten over now you're fair game for
being ticketed and you know you might
say why ten over why not three over why
not five over why not fifteen over and
but if you ask people they do have that
that in mind and be interesting to
compare this with kilometres to see
whether people you know in almost all
the rest of the world measure things in
terms of kilometres per hour would say
that it's ten or fifteen or five because
I'm willing to bet that that people
drive over the speed limit in other
places this view that sort of modifies
the strict application of the rule
there's what we call equity so that's
one example of it another example could
be for instance I have an attendance
policy in my classes and I allow
students to be excused for absences if
they have some sort of valid reason but
you know I also say well you have to
have something that's documental you
have to provide me with something so
your relative died show me an obituary
there could be some things where look
there's just not going to be
documentation possible and then you have
to make what we call a judgment call
judgment calls are corrections of what
we're calling legal justice where you
have some sort of norm in place and Jen
it's a good idea to stick to it that
it's a good idea to apply it across the
board but in this particular case that
would be less appropriate than providing
some leniency or saying you're getting a
warning this time or reducing the amount
that somebody is going to owe or
steering them towards alternate forms of
recompense you know there's a lot of
different possibilities here why is this
needed Aristotle says it's needed
because laws when they're put together
by their very nature they're framed
universally that is their frame to apply
to everything across the board whatever
it is that they happen to be about so if
it's laws pertaining the vehicles it
pertains to all vehicles if its laws
only pertaining to motorcycles it
pertains to all motorcycles right or it
may be indexed to a particular place
like all motorcycles in the state of New
York or all motorcycles in the
municipality of Kingston but you're
saying all so it's covering all of these
particulars the problem is is that there
can be cases where the law doesn't apply
well to some particulars this is not to
say that you know the law is no good
whatsoever as a matter of fact a well
constructed law should encompass most
cases that it's intended for but there's
there's always going to be some things
rising some some issues coming up where
somebody says yeah that if we if we're
really rigorous about this if we go
exactly by the letter of the law it's
not going to turn out the way that that
it ought to there's that sense that we
have that the law is there to you know
provide some guidance in the majority of
the cases but that it can't actually
apply to everything totally and so to be
a the type of person who wants a norm is
in places it must
be applied every single place exactly
the same Aristotle would say that person
they're just in one sense but they're
also missing a kind of justice that's
very important for human beings in
another sense they're more like a robot
than or you know some sort of animal
acting out of automatic reflexes then a
fully human being so there are some
cases where we have to we have to think
about how should we apply the law and so
this involves and he doesn't say this
per se but I'm using some more
contemporary terms it involves some
thinking Aristotle says one of the
things we ought to do is think about
what did the legislature or legislate or
you know depending on you know whether
it's one person or or many what if they
actually have in mind
when they were making the law or the
rule or the procedure or whatever it is
did they did what you're proposing over
here is that what they had in mind or is
that actually sort of a deviation from
what they had in mind that's a good
question to ask yourself judgment these
these sorts of things require judgment
which requires some cultivation on the
part of the person that's making it so
that they're not just making exceptions
for their friends and family or those
who they want to get in well with or you
know pick any sort of things along those
lines that would be self-interested in
actually unjust because they're not to
the benefit of the community probably
not to the benefit that people engaging
in that to get any real strict sense
another term that we use for this is
discretion and if we're thinking about
for example policing police often get
criticized because you know there'll be
a whole bunch of cars speeding and they
pull one person over and that person
will say why did you pull me over
they're going fast too
the cop might say something like well
you were going 15 over there all going
10 over it's up to my discretion who I'm
going to pull over I get to make that
that call when you're dealing with with
the police sometimes they have very
narrow discretion sometimes they have
wide discretion judges also have
discretion say in sentencing
sometimes laws could be passed that
restrict their discretion in sentencing
so there's a lot of ways in which this
might be thought of there's a lot of
contexts in which this could be applied
another thing that aerosol says it's
very interesting he talks about the
equitable person the equitable person he
says is if they're in a position you
know where they actually have some
authority then they'd probably be the
one to show good amount of discretion
that means they don't show discretion in
every single case because then it's not
discretion they're actually just not
applying the law but they are willing to
to then or lessen or you know turn the
law away from the strict rigor and
harshness that it possesses is universal
but as an individual they are prone to
be forgiving not in the sense of you
know putting up with anything whatsoever
but they're inclined to not insist on
their rights as opposed to other people
all the time you know you must give me
what is what is mine they're they're
willing to say well okay in this case
you know here would be a great example
noise laws right there's a lot of
municipalities that have noise
regulations and thank God for that
because I'm one of the people who are
well sometimes call the cops on noisy
neighbors because you know I don't want
to sleep or I want to read and I hear
thump thumpety thump I'm not very happy
so what if it's somebody's graduation
party that's a little bit different than
every Saturday nights
some jerks you know living it up and and
just making a lot of noise
maybe it's it's okay late you know later
at night on the weekends than it is on
on the weekdays even though the law says
across the board must be quiet by this
time the equitable person is the one
who's inclined to say in some cases well
that's that's okay I'll let that go I
don't need to insist on this and what's
really interesting here is that is a
form of being just aerosol saying so
what important type of justice which is
needed in order to correct legal justice
is equity that means that legal justice
can't be entirely what it's supposed to
be without this other type of justice
intervening just like we also need you
know when it comes to the particular
forms of justice we need justice and in
commutation or just distribution we need
rectification heed reciprocity they all
kind of fuse into each other and support
each other so that is equity